um
good morning or good afternoon dear
attendees
um of the discovery user symposium 2020
and this is dr kombak from
precision pathology by a banking center
of
memorial sloan-kettering cancer center
in new york
um our ppbc is the core facility for
research operations in mskcc
consisting of histology and immunostore
chemistry
labs and the biobank
i myself i'm a pathologist i
did my medical training and residency in
turkey
in istanbul and i've been working
in this facility
for almost
15 months now under a supervision of
dr roll dr silber and dr bennett
and with a great team of course
in this presentation i will try to
demonstrate
our multiplex immunothe chemistry
experience with you
[Music]
immediate chemistry experience using the
discovery ultra platform
first of all i would like to quickly
revisit the basics first
immunostar chemistry is a widespread
technique
which we use in our daily practices for
tumor diagnosis
and classification prognosis
and prediction and also for selecting
candidates for targeted therapies
with ihc we can selectively identify
antigens with specifically binding
antibodies
and visualize antigen antibody
interaction
with detection systems
there are a lot of detection systems
which
are direct conjugate labeled antibody
method
indirect or sandwich procedure unlabeled
antibody methods
whitens tryptophan systems and alkaline
phosphatase labels and polyvalent
detection systems
the most common one ones we use are the
peroxidase antiperoxidase method
and the ap anti-ap method
from all of these
we also need chromogens to visualize the
end product
chromogen is a color producing substrate
which is
activated with the enzymatic reaction of
the detection system
chromogens are either peroxidase based
or alkaline phosphatase or glucose
oxidase based
the most common ones are dab
aec and fast strat we usually use
in our daily routine
new chromogens are also emerging such as
horseradish peroxidase-based ones which
i will talk in detail
later here's a
simple demonstration of most common
chromogens
on the left hand side you'll see the red
membrane
staining of aec and on the right side
you will see
the brown membrane staining of the ap
there's been a growing demand
about immunostar chemistry like if
only they could label more than one
marker per section
or assess combined markers like pd1 and
pdl1
or be able to see the distribution of
immune cells
and interaction between between cells
and or
molecules and in the meanwhile to
preserve tissue and time
which these ideas led us to the concept
of
multiplex immunostory chemistry
today we have a bunch of different
techniques for
multiplex immunothe chemistry procedures
which are bright field based metal based
chip cytometry or dna barcoding based
methods
today i'll be talking about the
discovery ultra staining system which is
an example of bright field-based
multiple immunostatic chemistry
it is an automated platform for research
purposes
and it works with sequential cycles
without these staining steps in between
it uses chromogens with broad absorbance
spectra
and doesn't need as integrated scanner
or imaging microscopy or analytics
software
it is easy to perform and easy to
evaluate
and you only need a conventional bright
field microscope to evaluate the end
product
on discovery ultra staining system you
can combine
ap and hrp-based chromagens
in sequential cycles
so um to explain that after
de-paraffinization and pre-treatment
there
are consecutive cycles and antibody
denaturation steps in between
each sequence consists of primary
antibody
secondary antibody enzyme conjugate and
chromogen incubation periods
and after the last cycle there is
a step for counterstaining with a
hematoxylin
however five plex design consists of
pdl1
pd1 cd68 cd8 and cd3
antibodies and we combined
ap based red and yellow stains with
hrp based dab purple
and teal
pdl1 is the programmed
death elegant one which is a
transmembrane protein
that has been speculated to play a major
role
in suppressing the adaptive part of
immune system
that means the upregulation of pdl1 may
allow cancers to evade the host immune
system
many pdl-1 inhibitors are in development
as immuno-oncology
treatments and are showing good results
in clinical trials
so pdl-1 assessment has been a center of
interest for a while
just to show simple examples for
antibody chromogen couples in our design
you see here the bronze membrane
staining for
of the dab for pdl one
purple for pd1 there are some
teal staining and cd8 positive cells
around but the purple staining is still
distinguishable
red for cd68 to highlight macrophages
tl4 cd3 and yellow for cd8
um these two are usually intermingled
in our samples
we we applied this five plex protocol on
our collection of pontium or
tissue microarrays and these pontium
rtmas are
separate three separate blocks um with a
total of 144 cases
which are carcinomas of of different
origins like
lung colon stomach and gallbladder and
pancreas
as well as gastrointestinal stromal
tumors
sex course normal tumors and soft tissue
and bone tumors melanomas and
other rare and miscellaneous tumors
this application allowed us to have a
broad opinion on the distribution of
pdl1
and pd1 expression and the immune
response
in different type of tumors
here is an example
of a pdl-1 positive core
it is a nice display of the tumor and
the strong pdl bone positivity
and the
polyphonic immune response around it
and also within the tumor
if we look closer we can get a better
detail
of the pdl1 expression in the tumor
and also the immunoprofile of the
infiltrating cells in the scene
in some of the course we observed some
focal mild red staining mainly on tumor
cells
which seemed like a precipitation issue
and improved um
with an additional step of reaction
buffer rinse
and
after that addition i can say
that the background staining is minimal
as you can see here
even in areas with dense immune
infiltrators
a lot of positive cells
um another material we run the
procedure is the pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma
tissue microarrays which are
two separate tma blocks carrying
a total of 87 cases
45 of which are female patients and the
rest of
42 is are male patients
also 36 of them are short-term survivors
and the rest are long-term survivors and
the median age is
70.
i displayed this image to
give some opinion about how i
interpreted this
tma sections with the five flags
on the left hand side you will see the
green annotations for tumor areas
and on the right side you will see the
pink annotations for peritumeral stroma
as is known the tumor and stroma can be
very intermingled and pedex
and they both contribute to the
malignant process but still
this discrimination provided me so much
information about
the tumor-associated immune response
here is an example of a pita case with
some degree of pdl1 expression
[Music]
and also we can see the
infiltrating immune cells with
a different immunoprofile
you can also measure the proximity of
pd1 positive cells to the nearest tumor
cell
with using a simple
image analysis program or it can be a
freeware program online
i would also like to talk about another
design we
created using the new chromogens which
are
the beta products of roche tissue
diagnostics
and they're not commercially available
yet and they're still in development
and they are tirement based hrp mediated
chromogens
the procedure is sequential just
like the fiveplex design
this time only with the hrp-based
chromogens
so similarly after the paraffinization
and pre-treatment
there are three consecutive cycles
consisting of
primary antibodies secondary antibody
enzyme conjugate and chromogen
incubation
and in the end there is a step for
counterstain with hematoxylin
in this design we combined pdl1
and ttf1 pdl1 matching with
red chromogen and ttf1 matching with the
yellow chromogen both
are hiv-based and we
used six pulmonary adenocarcinoma cases
with
varying levels of pdl1
expression
here is the yellow nuclear staining for
ttf1 in tumor cells
and the red membrane is staining for
pdl1
and the combination you see here
um you see here the pdl one positive
and ttf1 highlighted tumor cells in the
upper half
there are also some other red staining
cells
beneath that part but
most of them are macrophages um
actually it is hard to discriminate on
monostain
whether the pdl one positive cell is
a really a tumor cell or a macrophage
especially in tumors with solid pattern
like this
and abundant macrophages around
they can be positive for pdl-1 and
easily be
misinterpreted as a tumor cell
so marking tumor cells with ttf1
at the same time um facilitates the
interpretation
and therefore provides
a better pdl one scoring
similar um to the
to this image in this one there is an
area of macrophages in the center of the
image
which can easily be identified as
pdl-1 positive tumor cells on monostain
and this is
another case showing a smaller
percentage of pdl1 positivity
and as you can see the staining
intensity is
variable from weak to strong in the
sample
um as an adjunct we decided to add
cytokeratin as a third antibody in the
design
so it would cross check and enhance the
efficacy of ttf1
um to detect the tumor cells
creating a discernible transition from
nuclear yellow staining to the membrane
and spread
staining
we use the same six lung cancer
cases again for this design and
you see here a part of benign epithelium
um staining with um
blue for cytokeratine and
yellow for ttf1
this is the case with a lower pd l1
positivity i showed you earlier with the
double design
now the tumor cells are highlighted both
with
a yellow staining of ttf1 and
blue cytoplasmic staining of cytokeratin
blue cytoplasmic staining off the
cytokines and makes it
easier to detect the red membrane
staining staining of pdl one
now let's review some comparison images
with the ab
this is a case with um
this is the case uh negative for um
pdl1 there is some
mild normal background staining with dab
which we don't see in the triplex design
and in this sample
it's a case with mild to moderate
positivity for pdl one
and i try to capture
the exact same areas to compare the
staining quality
i can say that
[Music]
the variation in staining intensity is
with the red chromogen is very similar
to dab
and the percentage of positivity is also
accurate
another case with moderate staining
red staining is moderate in intensity
likewise
the same subpopulation however on the
left side
seems um somewhat paler in both stains
this is partially because of the
infiltrating
lymphocytes which can easily be
recognized and ignored with ttf1 and
cytokeratin negativity in the triplex
design
and an example of strong positivity
when the membrane staining is strong we
usually get some cytoplasmic reflection
of
it with any chromogen
blue cytoplasmic staining of
cytokeratine also helps with that
by overruling that infusion-like
staining from the membrane
now a closer look and for the eggs to
the same area
the red membrane is staining is very
sharp and strong
just like the ab which gives me the idea
that it can be
implemented to her2 staining
also and also
a lot of other combinations can be
created
with other antibodies
so based on our experience i can say
that
discovery ultra staining system is
an efficient automated platform for
research purposes
on this platform you can combine ap
and hrp based chromatins and it's very
easy to perform
with the stainer you don't need to
integrate a scanner
or an imaging microscopy or analytic
software
and it's easy to review you only need a
conventional bright field microscope and
you see
all the
chromogens on the same slide under light
microscope
there may be a minimal overlapping
and minimal background staining and due
to
the utility of multiple chromatins but
if you have such a problem i can suggest
to add a reaction buffering step
after the problematic chromogen
incubation which
provided improvement in our case
and also the successful integration of
hrb based neurochromogens into the
sequential multiplex ihc
procedure is also promising for the
future of this technique
i would like to thank you for your
interest and
attendance on behalf of my team
and if you ever want to get in touch you
can just
easily send an email to me or to dr roll
and we will be very happy to communicate
with you
thank you